great to see you thanks for joining us
did you hear the minister
yeah she's it's so infuriating i'd love
to know her skills that
the part about her being a skills
minister skills in what
uh fear-mongering i mean look how can
you justify
that i mean how can why do they keep
putting nightclubs into one box
what do you what does she class as a
nightclub there's so many positive ways
of doing this you know they opened the
pubs without
you know the first thing they opened and
then the other week had an argument with
one of the health ministers on another
program
regarding the fact that she said alcohol
and social distancing don't go
so why did you open the pubs in the
first place you know it's about
positivity it's about sitting down and
working away
forward you know you're talking about an
industry that makes 70 billion
for the economy every year
i know and i put all of those points to
her um
she also went on to say that the reason
one of the reasons that we can't
have they've made it illegal to have
singing and dancing is that dancing is
very unpredictable
you know at the end of the day we're
living in a world where you can't sing
and can't dance
i mean that that in itself is just crazy
you know human nature to want to sing
and want to dance
the last two months alone there's been
more death from suicide
than there has from kovid you know that
has that comes at a cost telling people
they can't sing and they can't dance
comes at a cost
if you're wearing a mask like we're all
meant to be doing in within that
environment
why can't you sing if masks work to the
extent that they're meant to
why can't you sing if you were to open
nightclubs where people were fully
clothed and wearing masks on dance
floors
where there was no sweat there was
nothing and it was air conditioned done
properly it's all about positivity in
doing it properly
what is the problem she did go on to say
that
the hospitality industry had done very
well when it came
to coverage restrictions but still until
there was a long-term solution in her
words
nightclubs uh that overall that umbrella
that is uh the word nightclubs
will not be open we're looking at the
spring of next year what does that mean
for your industry
oh our industry's been on its knees for
the last six months you know the new
rules that
that richie brought in this week about
topping up people's wages these people
won't get wages because their premises
are sharp
they no longer be on furlough you know a
million people are going to lose their
jobs
a million people if this isn't you know
there was outcry when ba are threatened
to lose 12 000 jobs
we're talking about a million people
losing their jobs and they're and
they're interested
my job my career is not dispensable
it's not something you can throw away
i've worked a lifetime to come
to get to the point in my career where i
am you know it's not disposable
you know like any other one like an mp
or
a barrister we train to do what we do
it's not something that we do overnight
you know it's an art we i i work in the
arts and you know
just to say that's disposable and we'll
leave that on ice
you know and and let a million people
lose their job is despicable
no we're not saying let's open
nightclubs so everyone so the spike will
go up you know look
last in the last two weeks 3.2 percent
was responsible for the increase you
know from that from our section
and you know 25 come from care homes
and the rest came from offices and
factories why are they not shutting the
offices and making people work at home
when they're the main cause yeah i don't
know i didn't put that to her as well
um tony i sh one of the reasons that the
government will turn to
if we when we have this conversation is
we saw the pictures in
uh oxford circus at the weekend where so
many people were gathering you know they
were all thrown out at the same time
gathering having a party
it's their fault you know what
i was in oxford circus i was in
charleston avenue
on set on on friday night and both
saturday night after work and
you know firstly they they closed the
tube station
entrances at oxford circus because there
was too many people
right so what are those people meant to
do you're telling them they can't sing
and they can't dance inside
they're going to do it outside it's
human nature secondly
you know i tried to get an uber home
from charleston avenue
to pimlico which is a mile and a half
maximum they wanted 30 to 35 pounds
on a surge these are the things that
should be looked at not these videos of
people dancing in oxford street
you know they can't get on the tube they
can't get home what they meant to do
i'm not sticking up and we have idiots
from all parts of our society of course
people are going to take the law into
their own hands
because it's got to that stage where
they no longer believe in this believe
in this government or believe in our
police force because
they've been told you can't do this and
when you tell someone you can't do this
they want to do it even more it's like
you're not leaving the table till you
eat your green
scenario you have got a plan i believe
to try to relaunch um the uh
night life uh with music tell me about
it
well we've already started very
successfully a project called
socially discouraging and social just
going and and what we do at social
discounting is when you enter the club
you are temperature tested
you're tracked and traced straight away
onto a computer the whole thing is
thing you have to sanitize on each level
you go up you stay within the bubble of
six
your bubble on your table if you leave
your table to go to the bathroom at any
point or whatever you want to do
you have to wear your mask smoking areas
are completely contained
to your bubble only so if there's any
people from your table you go at a
certain time to smoke
and that's the way it should be and you
know it works and people are enjoying it
it's like dinner and chair dancing
people are dancing in their chairs
but you know it's suddenly they can no
longer dance they can no longer sing
people will still want to go out and
enjoy themselves i think that
if you if people want you bad enough and
they want to
go they will be responsible they will be
responsible which we've proven it
we've been out without with our new club
night that it
it that it works and i just think it's
about taking that responsibility
and being positive about it you know but
it's it's really hard to be positive
when
every day the new more and more
sanctions come out aimed at our
our sector you know why they not talking
about the offices why are they not
talking
about the care homes why do they keep
blaming on pardons
bars and bugs you know a month ago it
was eat out to help out our nation went
out to help out on a monday tuesday and
wednesday
when those people would normally be at
home with their families
but yet now they're out on the street
down the street queuing up to get into
restaurants
sitting next to each other in old
concert street or wherever they were
on mass that's why we have spiking this
is why we're striking eat out to help
out but the government won't take
responsibility for that oh no it's us
it's the nightclub sector it's the bars
it's the pubs
it's the restaurant and it's not okay
it's not at all you know
3.2 is not a lot yeah so each out to
help out was in august
uh in your opinion just before we let
you go when can we go out again
think you know uh as soon as the
government lifts this six or six and
stuff like that i think that
it's a it's a really really difficult
time for everyone and i think the more
creative we are and the more productive
we are and the more positive we are
about the world we're living in right
now the better it will be for everyone
and i think that everybody just needs to
be a little bit more creative
and come up with some new ways of
enjoyment okay in the meantime i'm
really enjoying your sets
on instagram thank you so much
okay thank you so much for having me
look after yourself darling thanks a lot
thank you
oh don't you miss going out i know i do